Sharks!
All right, we're here to pick up the Maki-E MontBlanc. I'm among one of 88 in the world.
This is number 13, and it's on its way into Mr. Wonderful's pen collection.
At the prototype, I shot that with Shark Tank. Here it is for the first time.
Wow! It's way bluer, way bluer than the prototype.
Beautiful.
Alright, let's pull it out there.
[Kevin] And I have my eye on number 13 as you recall.
[Salesperson] Correct.
[Salesperson] And, good news.
[Kevin] I got it?
[Salesperson] You got it.
Oh my goodness, It's gorgeous.
See that's a lacquering technique and diamond on the top. Number 13, very controversial number, that's what I like about it.
That is gorgeous. The craftsmanship on. Open it up let's look at the nib. That was another beautiful thing I liked about it.
Yeah.
Oh, isn't that gorgeous? Beautiful.
Absolutely spectacular.
Alright.
Now I'm going to put some blue ink in it to write for the first time.
A lot of people will not ever write with these pens.
They collect them only, keep them in this box, but not me.
I want to actually write with it, use it, live with it.
And then of course, I'll put it in my coffin because I'll need it in the afterlife
Alright.
Wow. That's so smooth.
One of these days the sharks are jumping out of the tank and eat one of these people. It's crazy.
This is a pitch being setup. Have a look at this.
Alright, Thank you.
That's fun.